Hello everyone, this is Frank Defrates, and welcome to Holotalk, the Internet's laser and holography talk show enjoyed in over 42 countries throughout the world.
And now, here's this week's show.
Hello everyone, this is Frank Defrates, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk.
My guest this week is Brian Monaghan of International Holographic Paper, located in Shelfont, Pennsylvania.
International Holographic Paper produces a number of different commercial holograms, and uh some of their recent projects that you may have had an opportunity to see would be uh their video boxes, for instance, uh at your local video store.
They were responsible for the Star Trek Generations, Matrix, and Men in Black, which actually was a production run of 27 million.
Uh they're also involved with a system that they developed called iScan, which is a new way of making dot matrix holograms through interferometric laser ablation.
And Brian Monahan is going to be coming on and telling us a little bit about that technique.
So let's move on to the show.
It was recorded on location in Shellfont, Pennsylvania, and let's hear what Brian had to say.
Hello, everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of Holotalk.
We're kicking off a brand new season of HoloTalk shows, and I'm here in Shelfont, Pennsylvania with Brian Monahan.
And Brian Monaghan is owner of International Holographic Paper.
And what I'd like to do at this point is to let Brian take a minute or two to let you know what International Holographic Papers is all about.
Well, um our company started in uh 1971, and we were basically in the paper business, uh selling commodity papers to commercial printing industry.
About nineteen eighty eight, took a course in holography with you down at the Franklin Institute, got hooked on it, set up tables in the basement, and uh figured out that there's got to be some way that we can make a living in this.
Uh around 1992 we uh purchased our first dot matrix photoresist hologram machine uh that would produce uh up to twelve by twelve inch images pixel by pixel, um, and uh really took off from there.
We basically uh design now we design all of our own custom holograms, uh electroform, emboss, and most of the material that we now distribute is still paper based, just holograms that are embossed into paper for mass replication, for uh anything from cosmetic packaging, video boxes, uh beer can labels, bribato labels, uh, and now a lot of point of purchase displays.
We're sitting here in a conference room where we are completely surrounded by projects that uh you have worked on with your company.
And I was uh wondering if you could take a moment just to look around the room and maybe pick out a few of the ones that are perhaps uh some special projects that uh you've worked on.
Well, it's a lot of these things were very interesting and fun.
Some were a hell of a lot more profitable than others, but um intricate.
Um just real quickly, a couple of them that stand out in the video boxes.
We won some awards for the Star Trek Generations video box uh and the matrix video box.
There were custom holograms and mass produced in large quantities.
Uh then simple ones like our Men in Black video box.
Um the Men in Black was twenty seven million video boxes produced all around the world.
Uh and it was done with a simple diffraction grading, uh cross grading, what we call rainbow.
Some of the other ones that are more in uh intriguing uh is in the C D ROM packaging.
We have one called Skynet there that was one of the largest holograms ever produced in its time about 14 by 20 inches and it had registered lithography with it to really make it stand out and be attractive to the consumers.
Some of the ones that I think we're most proud of and have fun with would be our latest series of Pokemon.
The Pokemon Craze uh really did a lot with holography the cards that we produced for the Topps company the last series was the introduction of six new Pokemon characters and it utilized a stereogram 2D, 3D um background image that uh had about 25 channels of movement in it in full color, as well as integrated dot matrix holography uh on the four forefront um with integrated holographic white.
So the cards were completely finished and didn't need to be printed on top of when it was done.
Then some of our latest developments that we did that were really a lot of fun were more on prototyping ends.
We'd shot a uh large Coca-Cola bottle about four feet high uh a bottle cap of uh beer on a Friday afternoon that we blew up to uh three by four feet and the latest one was the Ferrari and we just got finished shooting as uh 40 by 90 inches.
Um it required three holographic masters on our part uh and a very wide embossing machine ninety inches wide to replicate it but it it really stood out and it and it it really made us feel that we really achieved something being able to produce such a large image in under ten hours and very economically and get the results that we did.
It's an incredible piece.
The equipment that that was created on as far as the um actual equipment that exposed your photo resist.
Uh could you tell the listeners a little bit about that technology?
Uh of what you can tell about it anyway.
Well, uh basically we have three dot matrix machines, conventional dot matrix, uh, that expose photoresist uh pixel by pixel using uh blue laser, 442 nanometer wavelength.
And it goes through each pixel and rotates the diffraction grading pixel by pixel corresponding to a computer graphic.
We developed a new system on our own, it's called ISCAN.
Uh there is a video up on the website of iScan operating, and basically it produces uh holographic gratings size of pixels, uh about a thousand times a second.
And instead of exposing it indirectly into a photoresist that needs chemical development afterwards, this is basically etching for lack of a better term, directly into a piece of plastic, the holographic groove structures dot by dot by dot.
Um it's basically called laser uh ablation or interferometric laser ablation.
How many people do you employ here?
Right now there's twelve in our organization, uh eight people here, and mainly uh everybody we have one holographer and everybody else is in support.
It requires a tremendous amount of support in commercial uh in the commercial end of the business to show people, to educate them, um, to show samples, um and to get them understanding what they can do with holography and what they can't, uh, and how cost effective it can be when you put it on a package, it does cost more than white paper, but when it sells three times as much or you gain market share, it that comes back a hundredfold.
Exactly.
If there were students out there who were listening to this, perhaps they're in high school, they've worked on a holography project, they're very interested in holography.
What sort of skill sets do you look for?
What are the talents that are needed?
What do people need to know if they were to say, for instance, all of a sudden you needed to hire four more holographers?
Well, uh that's a very good question in that in today's marketplace uh companies are growing dramatically and there is a lack of skilled labor throughout the world.
Um holographers go from company to company, they're not born.
I think uh people that are interested in getting into holography uh are the type of people number one that love it, that do it in their basement and are amazed by it, and that's how I got involved into it.
Um if you love doing it, there's a way to find uh a way to make money at doing it.
Uh what we would require from people, tech uh specifically what I would love to have is a person who understands um uh programming, uh today's type of laser systems, uh stereographic, 3D, uh Pulse Portrait, a lot of different types of systems are all computer generated, computer controlled.
So knowing the the programming language is very important and staying up to date on that.
Computer graphics.
Um probably 75% of the commercial holograms shot nowadays are computer graphics, three-dimensional uh renderings, uh flat uh Photoshop graphics.
Not many models being made nowadays for commercial holography.
So understanding computer graphics is a strong point.
And then basis of holography.
Um understanding optics, optoelectronics, um, mechanical engineering, things like that are all important aspects of of how to put together a setup, how to operate a laser and and and what happens to polarization and things like that when you start bouncing off of different mirrors and different optics.
I don't know if that i if you need to walk in here and say I have a physics degree and this degree and that, but a very good understanding people who understand uh uh computer pro computers, programming, graphic arts, and um uh basics of holography with an emphasis also on on optoelectronics, the they're the kind of people that we would hire today.
I find it interesting that you also mentioned graphic skills along with that because a lot of times when we think about holography we think of it basically in terms of physics, optics and photonics.
But because the computer itself has made its way into so many areas of work today, I rarely hear it mentioned that computer skills would also be needed.
So it was interesting that you mentioned that as well.
It is important in one one respect is if you're a graphic designer you can be exceptionally well at it.
If you're a h a holographer you can be exceptionally good holographer.
But one necessarily can't work with the other.
A designer doesn't know exactly how to design to shoot a hologram and a holographer may not know how to design uh to begin with.
So you really need to have the best of both skills to be able to design what you want to get out of the finished hologram.
That's also taking into account different personality types as well because you have someone who's interested in physics and holography and that's a certain personality type of someone who's interested in science and technology.
And then you have someone who would be designing on one of your workstations and that's more of a creative type of personality.
So I can see where these careers are the future, and this is definitely one of the careers of the future, where you need quite a bit of a balance in an individual when you're looking to employ someone they need to be not only creative but technically savvy as well.
Do you see the field continuing to grow?
Very much so the projections that were done in I believe nineteen ninety seven estimated the worldwide commercial industry for holography at about one billion dollars.
Um that was reassured at our last conference in nineteen ninety nine in Florida at the Holopack conference they do estimate I believe in twenty oh two or twenty oh three to for it to double to be a two billion dollar industry.
When you're getting to be that size worldwide uh and that type of thirty to thirty five percent growth every year, it is something that a lot of people are paying more attention to holography has proven itself as a uh anti-the device uh holography has proven itself to uh capture attention uh and just have a aesthetic beauty to it.
So uh it is worldwide accepted and I do also see a lot of different companies within the industry spending a large amount of money on capital equipment, capital investments to be the leader in the future uh or to maintain staying the leader in the future.
So with all the money going into the industry and all the feedback from the uh consumers who utilize the holograms uh I expect at least for the next five, ten years to see uh this thirty percent growth.
With the technology changing as fast as it's changing now too, how often do you see it would be necessary to have one of your employees that's doing a holography learn new skills?
Well, uh the toughest thing about this business is being the best at it.
Uh to survive you need to be the best.
Uh you need to be new and you need to be unique.
The people who do that and spend the money on RD and development are the people that will exceed and are the people that have gained the reputation as being innovators within the industry.
As fast as holography in general or or lasers in general are changing, um, which is so rapid just from a few years ago having to, you know, buy tube d uh heaneys to the diodes now, the same thing is happening within the holography industry.
Um so you really need to be at the forefront of it.
Things that you machinery that normally would last in a printing industry, let's say for ten, twenty, thirty years, can become obsolete in two to three years within this industry.
So uh new product development, uh things of the along that line, developing new techniques uh uh in holography, not only to increase the efficiency, uh lower the cost, but to create new visual effects is something that's very, very important.
Um and you can say something new's coming out every year at least.
So essentially what you're saying is that you're the one that's creating the innovative changes and it wouldn't be that you would send someone out to learn something new.
You're doing that here yourself.
Yeah, uh basically you have to take there y there's no school to go to to learn the f fastest, newest things in holography.
So you have to teach yourself, um, you have to come up with ideas, uh, you have to spend the money and you have to try to execute those ideas.
Some things that we've tried have really paid off well.
Our eye scan is is a testimonial to that.
Um some things we've we've tried uh were ridiculous and uh we spent a lot of money and got nowhere.
But if we didn't try, we would have never known.
And I think a lot of people within the industry are doing the same thing.
Um and that goes back to the education end of it.
You've got to be smart enough and well rounded enough to be able to program, to be able to understand the optoelectronics, the physics, uh, and the basis of holography.
Knowing that you can go off onto these tangents and come up with ideas that may or may not work and try it.
But that's the only way to succeed is is to be one step ahead of everybody else and coming out with new and new products.
Well, you know I'm an old timer.
And when I look back, successful holographers were still in the basement.
And then I drive up to International Holographic Paper today and I see one of the most beautiful complexes that I've ever seen with holography anywhere.
This is beautiful.
Tell us a little about the building here, uh square footage uh for your warehouse and different areas like that.
Well, uh we came from an eight thousand square foot broken up facility in Glenside, Pennsylvania.
We had this purpose built for us uh about a year ago to this month as a matter of fact.
Uh and we designed it with expansion in mind.
Um we did a lot of separate special things for holography.
We have a uh uh 3D table in there that you saw set up, and that whole room is free-floating, that's on its own slab, it has isolation um uh material around the the slab, all the walls are uh floating off of the slab on a on a separate piece.
Little things like that have really helped in building this facility.
About 12,000 feet is production and warehouse.
And we're seeing uh we're running out of room very quickly as we keep vertically integrating.
Uh again with the the idea of reducing cost, giving better product and better services to our clients, uh, we're running out of space.
We do stock a tremendous amount of holographic material, uh generic for the uh worldwide commercial printing industry.
Um and we do see that as you vertically integrate, you can we're gonna need another 10,000 square feet very quickly, uh especially when you get into some of the large embossing and mass replicating equipment, the metalization, um coding and priming, things of that nature.
Before we close, could you tell the listeners a little bit about your website and what they would find when they go there?
Yeah, uh our website is uh WWW.
It's I H P hologram, H O L O G R A M dot com.
I H P hologram.com.
Basically, uh we have a couple videos up there explaining on how iScan works, uh also on how uh conventional dot matrix holography works, uh so you can have a little bit of a comparison between the old technology and the new.
And there's a lot of neat photographs up on the website showing a lot of our client projects, what we've been doing lately.
It's also a uh uh eFiles electronic newsletter that we send out on a monthly basis.
So if anybody would like to see what's going on in the realm of commercial holography, they can sign up and uh every month we send out something of new new projects that we're doing that they can see on their consumer shelves.
Okay, I want to thank you very much for being on the show, and I'd like to let the HoloTalk listeners know that there is a link right on the HoloTalk page for the International Holographic Paper website.
And I encourage you to click on that, go over and see what they're all about.
And Brian, thank you very much for coming on the show.
Thank you very much, Frank.